another day another superhero movie that
you probably forgot what's happening
gets pushed back i'm dave and this is
your mutation powered news update
superior movies maybe big box-office
draws but getting the made isn't
necessarily easy such as the case for
the x-men spin-off gambit between losing
a director last year and it's October
2016 release date disappearing from
schedules Fox aren't having much luck
getting it into production is now been
reported that the film has been delayed
yet again according to The Hollywood
Reporter gambit won't start production
until the end of 2016 this is
considerably later than the last
anticipated start date of March The
Hollywood Reporter States the film is
undergoing rewrites and at the director
doug liman may tackle another movie a
thriller titled the wall in the meantime
gambit was originally set to be directed
by rise the Planet of the Apes rupert
wyatt he left the project last
september's citing scheduling conflicts
however a story in deadline at the time
suggested that there may have been
ongoing disagreements over both the
script and the budget gambit will star
Chang Tatum as the car thrown super hero
of the title alongside spectres Leia say
do like Deadpool gambit is a character
spun off from the x-men first appearing
in a 1990 issue of the uncanny x-men he
briefly appeared in 2009 critically
panned x-men origins wolverine portrayed
by taylor kitsch so do you think we'll
ever see the ragin Cajun hit our big
screens let us know in the comment
section below or find me on Twitter at a
regular Dave and for the superhero news
keep tuned into gamespot com